what I'm arguing is we just can't say
hey the system is rotten and giving him
more to do it will just make it more
rotten the people that are advocates for
this kind of government-run state-run
preschool system believe that this time
they will get it right
back over there trying to to me get rid
of home daycare providers trying to say
you know the the preschool program in
the school district is better but it's
not better the universal preschool is a
big mistake there's a vigorous debate at
the country right now surrounding early
childhood education one thing everyone
agrees on is that our educational system
is in trouble if you look at all
different kinds of measures of student
achievement what you really see is like
a flatline
we're like 15th or 16th and in the
industrialized world simply not good
enough in fact we actually score worse
now on things like the SAT than we did
you know in 1971 we keep wanting to find
some silver bullet we you know we passed
this bill or that bill nothing has
worked
the latest silver bullet is called
universal preschool a plan that would
make publicly funded preschool available
to all four-year-olds on a voluntary
basis Oklahoma Georgia and Florida
already have universal preschool
programs in place and the movement is
gaining momentum the push to start early
has some powerful champions including
both the Democratic candidates I've
advocated universal pre-kindergarten
every dollar we invest in these programs
we get $10 back if adopted Barack
Obama's educational plan would increase
federal outlays to early education
programs by 10 billion dollars well
right now universal preschool the idea
of the earlier you start with a child
the more of advantage they will have has
really taken hold of the imaginations of
you know the people that run public
education in America there's nothing
more important in terms of life
performance than school readiness to
make their case universal preschool
advocates rely on studies of three
model programs these studies show that
intensive early interventions and the
lives of poor children can save
taxpayers money over the long term by
for example reducing dropout rates and
criminality we have got data that shows
the cost benefit these should not be
thought of as cost but as investments in
human capital critics argue that these
studies are irrelevant to discussions of
universal preschool because they're
based on small expensive programs that
provided poor families with a wide range
of interventions over several years
these kids got iron-fortified formula
they got parent training they got all
kinds of interventions that don't really
look like the kinds of proposals we have
today for universal preschool the best
evidence for the effectiveness of
universal preschool programs comes from
states like Oklahoma which has had
universal preschool for a decade
Oklahoma is one of just three states
that offer free preschool to any family
that wants it children who attend
preschool here scored 52 percent higher
in reading and 21 percent higher in math
and those who didn't children who attend
preschool in Oklahoma do score better on
tests and kindergarten but those results
appear to fade out within a few years in
1998 before they started doing universal
preschool they scored above average for
all of the states in the United States
ten years later after they've been
implementing universal preschool they
now score below the national average in
fourth-grade reading and math in
Oklahoma like the rest of the country
seventy percent of four-year-olds attend
preschool since there's no obvious
demand and we already have programs like
Head Start for poor children what
exactly is the argument for providing
publicly funded preschool to all
children
look Oklahoma and Georgia both have
programs just for poor kids they realize
quickly to maintain these programs and
love them to grow you have to serve
middle class children as well in order
to have that constituency they get
legislators say we're for this program
meeow levy is the owner of the
Manhattan Academy a Montessori School in
Manhattan Beach California there's a
certain segment of children whose
families cannot afford preschool if you
want them to have preschool help them
but you don't need to waste money
taxpayer scarce dollars on children
whose families don't need that kind of
assistance we all want high quality care
for our children so how does the current
competitive system stack up there's no
argument the quality of child care in
America by every measurement and every
study we have indicates it's somewhere
between poor and mediocre
probably the best judge of outcomes for
a three-year-old is the parents right in
recent statewide surveys eighty percent
of parents gave their child care
providers grades of a or a plus even
though the current system doesn't appear
to be broken universal preschool would
attempt to fix it by requiring teachers
to have credentials so right now in the
United States
a lot of people in the lower economic
strata serve children and sometimes
those workers are actually the sole
income earners of their families you
know they've started single women
businesses you know there's they've done
a lot of things for their communities
but they don't necessarily have
credentials so they would be the first
losers Marcella graves owns a home
daycare and preschool in Fresno
California joy is the children watching
them and grow learn learn from other
children learn to give care for each
other I love my job it gives me great
pleasure a person that wants to work
with young children is really a saint I
would say because it takes a lot of
patience anyone that's ever spent a day
with a four-year-old knows that it can
be a long day it's not about sitting
them down for hours and having them
learn and practice it's about engaging
them and making the day interesting if
universal preschool started tomorrow it
would put a lot of licensed providers
out of business
I don't have time to go back to school
to get my BA and work a full-time
business they're losing business I mean
they're concerned about staying in
business
my concern is about the development of
our nation's children adopting universal
preschool would result in a dramatic
decrease in choice for parents once you
start a universal program there would be
universal standards so what you're
talking about is more of a homogeneous
kind of an environment and you would be
losing out on some of the magic that is
preschool
you know another loser would be a lot of
the nonprofit groups that already serve
children like the ymcas and the Boys and
Girls Clubs and local churches and
community organizations it's very
difficult to compete with free universal
preschool critics argue that competition
is the best way to make sure we have
high quality preschools our schools are
of a high high quality
we're always reevaluating what we're
doing if we didn't we would be closed
down
public schools they're not doing it
they're not closed down they get to keep
going they get get to keep doing what
they're doing so what do you think is
universal preschool the best way to fix
our educational system we have to ask
ourself where will we invest our scarce
resources will we invest them in
universal preschool where the results
largely fade out by the fourth grade or
will we consider what we need to do with
k12 to make our schools more competitive
in general it's not as sufficient for us
to say K to 12 is failing we all kind of
agree that it is we've got to fix that
system the United States we do have
choice in education we have choice in
preschool and we have choice in college
it's just the k-12 sector where you know
the government and in
fools seem to be skeptical or have a
hard time with the idea of choice and
competition public schools are the
backbone of this society we're not gonna
get rid falak schools if they're not
good enough we've got to change them I
think that the public school system
should take a lesson from some of the
private sector and watch how we are
handling the operations of our school
what we need is more choices and more
competition so that kids have the right
of exit so they can move from one
program to another without being tied or
obligated to stay at one school that's
not working for them for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie
you